breathe how are you so I need I have a
question for you which glasses should I
wear should I wear the blue ones
hello Matt how are you oh my gosh
careful dog crazy we are here at Disney
and I'm extremely excited because I
haven't been here in a long time since
they have like all the Christmas
decorations and stuff up they also have
all of the Star Wars things because if
you guys missed the memo Star Wars and
Disney they're now together Matt how are
you doing you have a minute isn't yet
either
first time right first time at
Disneyland yeah yeah and we also were
gonna be going to California Adventure
which is kind of cool because you see
all of the cool like California spots
this is where MLG Anaheim was every year
never even came here Convention Center
VidCon as well I've been to a couple of
those Ana Anaheim MLG you did I had no
idea what was going on and you didn't
even talk to him to do I was really
nervous back that everything well no and
I think Ryan was in a rush to go home
he was that was it he did he pulled
Jenna away didn't you guys him get to
have the meeting he said let's go let's
go where Disney with the fam can you
guys believe you guys are here so
exciting I've always wanted them to come
visit and finally they got on a plane
flying if you've never really flown very
often yeah Bree made him she had no
choice she guilt-tripped him breathe
good at that owner for a couple days
well I'm very excited you guys are here
and yesterday we had a great time at
Home Depot my dad got me all the things
that you know you should have
this is a nice getting reggae I have
never seen frozen abusing frozen I love
frozen frozen you saw it they were my
favorite movie really the 60th
celebration I can't wait to see the
Diamond Castle it was close the last
time here some really excited to see
what it looks like now I'm sure it's
beautiful I've seen pictures but I want
to see with my own eyes
first off a Disney is clearly going to
Starbucks it's very very important
we're getting it again you have pressure
pressure
yes would be great week everyone
no I don't fit me into that I need to
get a chai latte
we're now entering these Star Wars
season a divorce I'm not actually sure
what is all new hair it's louder than
problem out of them time I really really
have to use the restaurant today so just
kind of rename sort of different rides
so it's not Space Mountain it's
hyperspace Mountain Star Wars path of
the Jedi we should we should the way
parents aren't gonna they're not be into
that one so that could be a give me a
hint only ride it was I drop my Buzz
Lightyear Legos you can get right off
okay we would be the eighth car
yeah but you want baby hate should we
get it are they supposed to be I think
they're supposed to be which needs to be
dirty these me out around the desert are
they supposed to be dirty
okay so making sure you carry the truck
that's very true maybe on the way out I
had a confirm you're supposed to be
dirty
I love all the amazing theme drink
containers they've got TIE fighters
they've got Darth Vader
yeah bb-8 I've seen actually named Darth
Vader might be for the candies
the trash burning things oh yeah or the
Sun or what do you what didn't make it
out
spoiler alert Jenna Matt newsy mom dad
I had 260,000 Fincher open I'm very
proud I just worked really hard
maybe because Mac I'm sending your cards
the Christmas version is sober
this is so good you call this play on
how do I win this I'll go with you
do you want to go all I ever wanted on
this winter day
hug
this thing didn't miss a thing you got
this
I wasn't even on the sled I was last
hello
oh my god
all right so we're about to go on the
California let's call the cars ride
we're in California venture right now
and I needed to charge my phone we just
show them this real quick sure Justine
gonna put up to your head
cover your head
well safe under the rich
are you creeping on my sister see what
she does when I put the light yeah she
did look you wanna she'll give you a
shot
man yeah you guys look cute hey how'd it
lose your favorite Star Wars movie here
we have the hypose six cent smart
battery case I thought I would go ahead
and unbox it for you because you know
you've got a lot going on